sausage party was a surprise hit in 2016
but the r-rated animated sex comedy has
generated plenty of controversy
interestingly not all of the uproar has
centered on the film's on-screen madness
there's also plenty of backstage drama
as well here's a look at the untold
truth of sausage party it started as a
punchline back when Seth Rogen Jonah
Hill and Michael Cera were promoting the
2007 hit super bad Rogan says
journalists would ask them what their
next movie was going to be as a joke
that's a sausage party reasoning that a
title like that would fit with
journalists expectations of the kind of
movie that make next nearly a decade
later when Rogen had the idea of making
an r-rated cartoon he kept coming back
to the name of that fake movie and
ultimately he and his writing partner
Evan Goldberg devised the concept and
script around the name nobody wanted to
make it after Rogen and Goldberg
developed the story in artwork they
teamed up with co-directors Conrad
Vernon and nitrogen head greg tiernan
and then well nothing happened for years
they pitched the movie to literally
dozens of studios and even considered
seeking private investors when they
invariably got shut down
even with Rogen and Jonah Hill attached
the star there seemed to be no studio
willing to gamble on average adult
cartoon tackling religious themes
Rogen's mission of making an r-rated
Pixar movie dragged on for eight years
until the team eventually got the
support of Annapurna
and Sony Pictures who apparently just
really wanted to see horny food come to
life and really is that's the MPAA said
n are the version of sausage party that
ended up in theaters pushed plenty of
buttons but believe it or not the movies
original cut took tinks even further
Rogen told Howard Stern this was by
design as they added six things to the
climactic food orgy as sacrificial lambs
to appease the MPAA and avoid an nc-17
rating much to their surprise though
most of these things actually made it
into the final cut the board in
sted focused on just a single bit the
hairy genitalia belonging to a piece of
pita bread which they digitally shaved
in order to make an r-rating a whole new
world if you picked up a distinct Disney
vibe while watching sausage party it
probably wasn't just because of the
animation oscar-winning composer Alan
Menken whose credits include such
classics as The Little Mermaid Beauty
and the Beast and Aladdin was hired to
compose the score as well as the
show-stopping opening number it may seem
surprising to longtime Disney fans but
according to Menken his decision to take
the job wasn't much of a shock to people
who know him in real life he told The
Hollywood Reporter I remember telling my
daughters that I was doing a project
sausage party and they looked at me and
went dad sausage party in real life I'm
actually a very r-rated person it almost
had a different ending Rogen screamed an
early count of sausage party at the
South by Southwest Film Festival in the
spring of 2016
telling attendees that they were truly
seeing something that no one will ever
get to see in the world and it turned
out he was right in more ways than one
that versions ending found the
characters exiting the animated world
and entering real life like in the last
act of the lego movie but Rogen
ultimately opted to go a different
direction for now as he later told fan
tango if they may actually end up using
that idea for a potential sequel the
idea of a live-action animated movie
like a who framed roger rabbit style
hybrid is also very exciting mostly
because Who Framed Roger Rabbit is one
of my favorite movies of all time drawn
and quartered conditions may have been
bad for some unlucky food in sausage
party but if allegations prove to be
true they weren't the only ones to
suffer according to allegations from
former workers at nitrogen Studios the
company responsible for the animations
kept its cost low by forcing employees
to work overtime for free under the
threat of losing their jobs
dozens of animators left the studio over
the course of the production claiming
that if they didn't stay late or work
that weekend for free there were
would be given to someone who would the
subsequent exodus of talent for start
region to hire recently graduated
students to complete the film while some
animators claim nitrogen even threatened
to smear their reputations as well
further allegations have surfaced that
many of the animators who worked on the
project were uncredited nitrogen has
denied all claims but it may be worth
noting that of the eighty-three sausage
party animators listed on IMDB only 47
were listed in the credits surprising
Dory
sausage party folks and general fund
industry leader Pixar by having the
character druggie drive a car with a
dicksuck bumper sticker and the license
plate a113 which is a recurring Pixar
Easter Egg referring to the animation
classroom at the California Institute of
Arts where a lot of animators got their
start
but the biggest prank sausage party
played on Pixar was entirely accidental
shortly after the monster hit finding
dory opened to record-breaking crowds in
June 2016 a theater full of kids at the
Brendan Concord 14 movie house in
California were accidentally shown the
ultra filthy red band trailer for
sausage party
whoops the theaters VP of Operations
Walter I can go quickly issued an
apology playing that trailer was a
one-time honest mistake by a theater
manager of moving screens around in an
effort to accommodate several large
last-minute groups wanting to see dory
we regret it apologize for it and we're
not happy that it happened but I will do
that patrocle classic rock singer meat
loaf makes a cameo as what else a boxed
made life
[Music]
literally nobody else could work for
that role so Rogan had no choice but to
lock down mr. loaf during a Q&A after a
screening of sausage party at the 2016
San Diego comic-con Rogan said he
personally met with Meat Loaf to pitch
in the pot afterward Rogan says he was
met by just 20 seconds of silence and
then he said yes I get it
did he no he didn't speaking of cameos
Sean puffy combs was almost in the movie
Rogan steam purge comes for a cameo to
voice a bottle of Courvoisier cognac but
when it came time to record his lines
did he drop the app the reason he didn't
want to provide a voiceover for a
cartoon Rogan says Combs understood that
the movie was about food come to life
but he apparently thought it was live
action and he thought he and other
performers would be wearing food
costumes now that would have been
amazing thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]